hospitales desbordados crematorios
llenos chinas se enfrentan una ola de
infecciones por Kobe 19 sin precedentes
pero el gobierno sigue defendiendo su
respuesta a esta nueva epidemia
estamos adaptando nuestras medidas de
respuesta al covid a la nueva evolución
de la epidemia y el desarrollo
socioeconómico actualmente la vacunación
de refuerzo avanza de forma ordenada y
los medicamentos y reactivos de análisis
pueden satisfacer en general la demanda
sin embargo las autoridades declararon
que ahora solo se contabilizan en las
estadísticas los fallecimientos causados
por neumonía e insuficiencia
respiratoria en pacientes que tenían el
virus por eso china no informó el
miércoles de nuevas muertes relacionadas
con el covid un cambio de metodología
que alertó la Organización Mundial de la
Salud
la OMS está muy preocupada por la
evolución de la situación en China con
informes crecientes de enfermedades para
poder hacer una evaluación completa de
la situación sobre el terreno la OMS
necesita información más detallada sobre
la gravedad los ingresos hospitalarios y
las necesidades de apoyo de la UCI
el comentario Se produce mientras el
gobierno alemán confirmó que ha enviado
su primer lote de vacunas
para ser administradas inicialmente a
expatriados alemanes china cuenta con
nueve vacunas covid de desarrollo
nacional más que ningún otro país pero
ninguna ha sido actualizada para la
variante omicron